allez les troisièmes aujourd'hui ces
randos regardez c'est super mais avant
ces
bombes ne sont pas bons ce coup là on
n'est pas dans ton canapé à regarder un
prix pourquoi tout le monde de voir
alors et les randonnées moi je préfère
rester chez moi à regarder des films en
fait aucun des formes là bons ne seront
pas prêts
[Musique]
vous savez nous on s'était promis de
participer à un film mais le problème
c'est que on n'a pas d'idées mais si là
j'ai plein d'idées et ça vous dit
comprendre c'est pourquoi du film
scolaire mais on va être filmé c'est
hyper chaînon c'est sur quoi c'est sur
les thèmes les sens et demi on pourrait
tourner un rejet en bouteille comme
ben alors roche écrite c'est super
concept du mal à tenir celle là vous
n'avez pas de vision on faire une
histoire empêche juste une randonnée
mois les sentiers demande il s'appelle
penser à l'écologie et voyez préserver
la nature tout ça à doral échos
d'aujourd'hui
imaginez vous une randonnée où les
randonneurs disparaissent au fur et à
mesure ils se font kidnapper mais en
fait le kidnappeur c'est thibault
mais attends ils disparaissent août et
randonneurs inondera son mystérieux
macabre et sataniser avec aïcha on peut
faire une musique effrayante bon à la
flûte et piano c'est a super bien ronde
non mais ça ne marche pas du tout la
reprenons imaginer que les randonneurs
et une solution d'échapper en trouvant
un oiseau magie sur à des sentiers et si
on lui donne à manger on gagne en
pouvoir mais comment tu veux faire un
avion qu'il allait commencer un jour
j'espère faire paraître
des effets spéciaux
nom n'a pas le budget un costume tient
là sous la main ça aurait jamais
autrement pourquoi tu veux partir sur
une fiction les sentiments ni ça
pourrait être un documentaire sur tout
et surtout de la rhino
[Musique]
et à consulter en d'hôpitaux récemment
il y à 1000 kilomètres de sentiers
pédestres à on y passerait trois ans 7
mois et 5 jours on a trois semaines je
reprends imaginer que les randonneurs
ben ils se retrouvent tous dans un
endroit grand escalier vous avez déjà lu
jus stephen king ou bien vu shining vous
connaissez rien mais c'est super
flippant tu veux qu'on ait peur
thème avoir peur c'est exactement ça
bon reprenons
genève seul sait quoi disparaître dans
un endroit où vous devez trouver la
sortie c'est largeur c'est une question
de sa vie vous comprenez
[Musique]
je
et couper c'est dans la boîte
benoît ton idée à marche plutôt bien et
oui
enfin je sais plus là
je sais plus non franchement super no 1
mais ça fait très sûr que je vous fais
ch vous étiez
on a tellement eu peur ce jour là
qu'aujourd'hui a pas pu venir c'est
vraiment dommage on n'était pas inspiré
par la nature mais ça rend plutôt bien
ouais tu peux aller dans restes humains
avaient appelé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]